bonjour faire un cas de massy
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin
en direct sur rt france la république
tchèque nous qui ne fait pas exception
avec ce durcissement des restrictions
sanitaires et l'obligation maintenant
pour les salariés de se faire tester
deux fois par semaine comment est-ce que
ça va être mis en place comment est-ce
que c'est accueillis dans le pays
ben évidemment comme dans beaucoup
d'autres pays il ya un ras-le bol parce
que ce sont des mesures qui dure qui
dure qui suivent d une campagne de
vaccination qui avait été présenté comme
une solution définitive
donc il y à il y à un mélange de
lassitude et d'agacement cependant la
cicc qui vient de se doter d'un nouveau
gouvernement
donc il ya une période d' état de grâce
on va dire les gens sont prêts à faire
plus ou moins un effort semblerait-il il
ya très peu de sondage qui permettent de
vraiment
appuyer les dires mais il semblerait que
les gens soient prêts à faire encore un
effort
sur une mesure de ce genre qui est
annoncée pour être vraiment sûr un délai
relativement court
sachant qu'en parallèle le nouveau
gouvernement ne joue pas la même
partition que l'ancien gouvernement le
nouveau grenier en place dans deux puits
depuis décembre et
est notamment le partenaire principal de
coalition dans le nouveau gouvernement
puisque c'est un gouvernement d'une
coalition de cinq partis
le
qui est menée par un parti d un parti de
centre droit
le partenaire principal stamm qui est un
fait c'est pas vraiment un parti au sens
français c'est une coalition de mer et
de haies et d'indépendance de maire
indépendant eux ce sont très clairement
exprimés contre l'obligation vaccinale
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui est très
important et qui est un changement dans
la politique tchèque puisque l'ancien
gouvernement s'était prononcé à la fin
de son mandat le monsieur ma biche
s'était prononcé pour l'obligation
vaccinale pour certaines catégories de
la population pour les travailleurs de
santé les enseignants et de président
milos zeman qu'on voit à l'image en ce
moment même et qui est aussi en fin de
mandat lui s'était exprimé pour la
vaccination obligatoire également donc
il semblerait que le nouveau
gouvernement ne soit pas pour la
vaccination obligatoire et ça ça permet
de descendre d'un cran dans la tension
en tchéquie oui et donc peut-être de
respecter des mesures moins
contraignante avec ces tests est ce que
concrètement ça va être possible à
mettre en place comment est ce qu'on
fait pour faire tester deux fois par
semaine quand on veut aller travailler
oui ah bah c'est une des questions qui
est souvent posée alors parce que du
coup vient la fin c'est une question de
logistique pour beaucoup de gens c'est
quand même une perte de temps terrible
en plus d'être un inconfort et voire
d'être quelque chose que tu eux aussi
considérés comme com
comme humiliant ou
extrêmement irritant et
bref tous ceux qui tous ceux qui ont
fait des tests savent de quoi il
retournait alors qu'on sait en plus
c'est régulier c'est quelque chose qui
peut être vraiment agaçant en
particulier pour des gens qui pensaient
être
tirée d'affaires en faisant le vaccin
donc là dessus on va voir comment ça se
met en place parce que ça va être un un
un essai à grandeur nature
il y aura certainement des complications
et un impact aussi sur la vie économique
il avait le travail beaucoup de gens
vont essayer de d'opter pour le
télétravail évidemment ceux qui le
peuvent c'est pas le cas de tout le
monde
j'ai fait d'exploit il n'y a pas
d'obligation de télétravail comme en
france en tchéquie
non non non il n'y a pas pas vraiment
maintenant d'un autre côté les
travailleurs du tertiaire ont et de sons
sont beaucoup plus beaucoup plus adapté
à sa déjà on va dire il n'y a pas la
même il n'y a pas la même culture de
travail qu'en france et il ya une plus
grande souplesse là dessus
comment est ce que est ce que selon vous
la la situation sanitaire en tchéquie et
quelle est elle et est-ce que ça
justifie justement le fait qu'on
renforce encore les restrictions
sanitaires dans le pays
entier qui comme ailleurs le
il semblerait qu'on soit en pleine vague
au micron et il ya beaucoup plus de
tests et donc sans surprise il ya
beaucoup plus de cas en revanche ce qui
est certainement beaucoup plus
importants a noté c'est qu'il y à un
effondrement dans le nombre de gens
hospitalisés donc à partir de là est ce
que tout ça est justifié sa ce débat à
titre personnel je pense que non je
pense que considérant
la couverture vaccinale puisque c'est un
des arguments principaux qui avançaient
depuis un bon moment et considérant le
dangerosité et dodo microns
on voit bien sûr que on voit bien que
c'est un c'est invariant qui est quand
même très peu
par rapport aux variants précédent voilà
il ya c'est un combat donc donc à partir
de là honnêtement là je pense qu'il faut
il faut vraiment revenir à la normale à
la raison voilà c'est un avis personnel
mais en tout cas quand on voit les
chiffres aussi en tchéquie comme je vous
disais explosion du nombre de cas
effondrement du nombre
d'hospitalisations
ça paraît difficile de maintenir de
telles mesures
revenir à la normale c'est ce que prône
l'espagne rétrogradé cette épidémie
absolument merci beaucoup feirense
almaci d'avoir répondu ce matin en
direct avec nous à nos questions sur
arte france